we are so glad that you are here it is a
very special day because we are trying
something that we've never tried before
we've got a full hour
of true news
we're news and across the usa with
check-ins from our affiliates coast to
coast and wait until you see who's
coming to the table let's do this
[Applause]
joining me at the desk as always is my
trusty co-pilot rossi ross matthews
[Applause]
oh my god
omg omg
what a day
and the team from cbs mornings gayle
king tony decouple and nate miles
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i'm proud to say that you and gail have
been here
but tony
who i got to fill in for while you were
on paternity leave thank you for welcome
i'm so happy to be here
thank you thank you for the warm welcome
i really appreciate it uh you know the
babysitting offer is still available if
you'd like to come by anytime and take
the kids i can't tell you what an honor
it was for me to get to fill in for you
for two days when you're on paternity
leave like i felt like i had arrived in
my life i kept bragging from like
was just so incredible all right well
let's get to some headlines first we
gotta start with the woman who's always
the number one headline in my heart
oprah winfrey oh
[Applause]
it was really magical listen you don't
realize how much well maybe you do
realize how much you miss her because
she's certainly one of the greats when
it comes to her voice and it was you
know a very small group of people number
one the setting was so pretty you just
felt elevated really yeah
i was told that adele believe it or not
was very nervous and so you know she
came up with a guest list of people that
she knows and she wanted it to be she
wanted it to feel very familiar when she
walked out that's what i was told
and so
you know it was a very small group of
people it was very nice it was very nice
um i love seeing leonardo dicaprio there
because i didn't see him there i heard
he was there i did not see a little mask
down there was a moment oh yeah i was on
leo watch 2021.
he like loaded it for a second and you
could see it but i heard that he was
there he was and apparently adele had a
titanic themed birthday party
because she loves the movie that much
and he came so they're friends and that
was fun oh that's nice i know oh wow
well huffpost is reporting that oprah's
singing really stole the show it's this
post that oprah put up herself and the
clip has gone viral it's oprah singing
along so hard and maybe not knowing all
the words which is so true let me see
i don't think that's true i love that
she put this up i love that i can't tell
you i have to call foul on that what i
have to call fell on that only because
she has spent the last last three four
weeks preparing for this interview and
all she's been doing is listening to
adele songs all she's been doing so
maybe they caught at a bad time i think
they did but she posted it i loved it
yeah i'm sure she did i was like
it's one thing to listen it's another
thing to sign yeah
and we all know
even on her show all the time they would
cut to her singing and she never knew
the words and i love that she doesn't
look like they weren't like
that
right that is true i will say that is
true yeah because she's not a big music
person to be you know perfectly honest
with you but with adele she had been
listening to all of the music but i hear
you nate she's been listening to all of
the music so she was ready i've done
that every like day of my life i'll go
in for the big and be like
yeah we we talked to we have a lot of
musicians on the show uh anthony mason
does fantastic individual musicians uh i
had an interview once with linda
ronstadt oh i love him
one of the great singers of all time and
she gave me some good advice that i
think supports oprah and her endeavor
here don't leave singing to the
professionals yeah
we should all belt it out from time to
time
whether you know the words or not or not
yeah that's what she said yeah can i ask
you have you ever been to karaoke with
oprah she she's not a karaoke girl i'm
telling you can you imagine
it's not it's honest to god it's not her
but you guys have taken road trips
that's a really good point
to the point that nate is making we've
done road trips she can ride in the car
who does this with no music
she prefers to ride in the car as she
said to me to be alone with her thoughts
i go but you're not alone
that's what she said to me let me dive
into this game
so girl i've been working with you for a
little bit yes and you know right
and i know you love to sing and you know
i can't sing that i know you can't see
that's where you're going so do you
think maybe oprah said that because she
don't like you'll see it
no
all right well
everybody is buzzing about the new
princess diana movie called spencer and
there's one scene in the movie that
seems to be shocking everybody it's
almost too hard to believe it shows
princess diana showing up to the royal
christmas festivities and she's asked to
step on a scale true
well marie claire reports this is 100
real life apparently it's been a royal
christmas tradition for over a hundred
years guests are weighed in when they
arrive at the party and then wait again
before they leave
because if they say if you haven't
gained a few pounds you didn't have
enough christmas fun
i'll tell you right now if i go to your
party and you have me get on a scale you
know what you're getting for christmas
is a scale in your face
no
no
i agree with you i mean if you're
showing up looking to have a good time
you do not want to be reminded of that
number on the scale hello but if you're
at somebody's house and you're their
guest and they say
i wouldn't refuse to do it i would think
it was i would think
on the scale and post my weight you know
when people say god i can't believe you
post your weight i said i have a mirror
i know what it looks like i'm under no
illusion about it but if you go to
somebody's house and that's their
household you wouldn't get on the scale
nate i would yeah if it means i'm eating
well
when you first started off the whole
crowd's like oh my goodness
but then you brought it all full circle
by saying you get on the scale because
that shows that you enjoyed yourself a
little bit of food a little bit of
drinks i think that's all right and it
all comes back to fashion it helps
explain why princess diana was such a
big fan of the bike short look
particularly around the holidays yeah
like that wouldn't add any extra weight
to the scale wouldn't add any weight but
also it's a little comfortable it gives
it's a stretchy material
i think this is so would you get on the
scale drew i i would get on the scale
and i would say
um
you know
uh
please let anyone off the hook who
doesn't want to do this yes i would say
queen you first get on there first
let me see you on it
and i want you to wear the crown too but
that's heavy
[Music]
you